[Music]
and welcome back to the camera boys we
got an amazing episode of the hot seat
here featuring mr eric him over here
here we are in the hot seat where we got
the hottest seat in the game with the
harder questions and all that [ __ ] but
we like to start off the the questions
on the hot seat very cold and then
throughout this video we're going to
turn up the heat but uh to start we
always have bart with the coldest of the
iciest questions which flavor of
starburst do you hate the most it's got
to be the lemon the yellow one a lot of
people are like me too i don't like that
one you don't like the taste of plates i
care about our skin color so we don't
like the lemon that's why it tastes like
lemon i could throw that one away yeah
it's like lemon pledge you know as a kid
you know your your mom would be walking
like clean downhouse 11 pledge yeah and
when they spray it you get that flavor
in your mouth
and then when you open up the starburst
everyone loves the pink right like the
pink and red pink is the good yeah when
somebody gives you a yellow like [ __ ]
not the
or the orange one the orange one's like
why you know what the yellow one is
banana in the blue colored starburst got
it got it
okay
but in this classic it's lemon no more
banana candies
i'm not mad at the orange one
okay i'll turn up a little bit
you're a finance guy right you're still
fine ass guy what what uh uh what age
did you earn your first six figures and
how did you celebrate that's a good
question yeah that's a really good
question
um it was when i started my i've been an
entrepreneur since i was 16. i'm like 43
now i didn't get my first six figures
until i started my tax business 13 years
ago
and how do i celebrate i really didn't
celebrate i just kept grinding it like i
was i had this this toxic hustle culture
like work type of thing and i was just
so lost in the sauce
that like when i got it and i saw my
bank i'm like just another number just
kept going oh [ __ ] wow that's cool and
now like i'm finally at a point where
i'm like i should start celebrating my
wins and stuff like that but back in the
day dude i celebrate [ __ ] how do you
celebrate your wins now um either go out
to grab something to eat with my son
yeah or um you know i'm not like a big
like buy myself something cool although
i i do buy myself something cool every
now and then yeah um but yeah i usually
go out to eat with my son or something
like that i'm like dude we made it we
did this what's the last coolest thing
you buy yourself
oh it's gotta be my porsche what kind of
porsche is it it's a uh so it's a 987
boxster it's like a canyon carver i love
the thing it's slammed to the ground got
coilovers big wheels all that stuff so
much freaking turns like a champ yeah
it's so much fun your uh son's 18 right
yeah have you guys ever thrown down
before oh
dude last so last year that's a good
question that's a great question because
if ty man a minute tiger's 18 and he
[ __ ] talks back
his ass so we i we've never we've never
actually gotten to like any type of like
argument or fight like he's super chill
like i'm a super chill person but like
in terms of like
like throwing down instead we would get
down so like when he turned 18 he wanted
to go to his first music festival so
he's like dad i want to do edc and i was
like all right let's do edc we end up
raging hard did you do the first part of
the edc
the e part the e part of it
i was with you i was like what's the
full experience
what's the one i was like what is it
there's a pre-party
i was like there's another one well the
tailgate did you guys have any
prescriptions
no actually we were like totally sober
and it was a good ass time yeah
i can't wait to drop with the taika
would you drop e with taika [ __ ] yeah
that's tight the minute he turns age so
probably like 14 15. wow wait did that
actually that's what i started i want to
pass it down and i feel like the
experience would be so [ __ ] sick
because you know like you and like
parent and kid you always have like
there's this there's a gap right because
you're like trying to parent you know
like as much as tight as you want to be
there's still that and to be able to
break down some barriers you just
connect just don't tell social workers
you're going to let your minor drop you
with you
that's why
allegedly
wouldn't that be a great experience
conceptual situation i used to smoke
weed with my friend's mom
that was cool and every she worked at
mcdonald's so every time i went to
mcdonald's she would hook us up with
yeah extra cheeseburgers
and she's talked like this because she
smoked a lot of cigarettes she didn't
smuggle from here
with a gravel voice
you're gonna be a man today joe
a mcmahon your boys are some good boys i
put on extra chicken nuggets for you
i got another question for you
uh
has
any of your friend
[Music]
uh tax
professionals been asked to help
launder and wash money and what was the
craziest like proposal your friend
got
[Laughter]
well my friend
yeah yeah yeah yeah this guy gets it
this guy is good
weird heir dude
allergy seasonality
i mean the
the weirdest i don't even think that
they're weird because i've seen so many
different things yeah um but usually it
usually revolves down to using like
international shell companies and stuff
like that
so they are technically legitimate if
they're done properly but there's a lot
of structure that's happening to it so
hypothetically how do you do it properly
[Laughter]
i think here's a better question so like
so so there are a lot of loopholes right
and um things that are unobtainable for
maybe someone at the like low million
range but then you have all these
billionaires and everyone who can do
offshore and all this stuff um at what
point do you think it's actually worth
it to to spend money to doing that
because basically the way they're
looking at it is like do i take the tax
hit or do i spend money and create like
an irish corporation or whatever it is
um
and then so i'm always looking at the
threshold like okay when is it makes
sense for someone like i don't know
google or like jeff bezos or whatever to
[ __ ] go out and do this but what
about guys that own a donut shop and
then we have like three shops like do
they need a cayman's account like no
probably not
but then yeah so i guess what type of
revenue or is it a revenue what's the
threshold yeah what is the point income
threshold
it comes down to a couple things like
what type of industry or business that
they're in
right so like the the caymans and what
they call the irish thing is double
double dutch sandwich where basically
they have
some other company in ireland or
whatever holding intellectual property
and there's like a leasing agreement
that happens between each other and that
moves that money offshore but to operate
that thing properly you need a big four
accounting firm you're paying millions
of dollars to make that run so you're
probably in the 50 millions a year yeah
just to operate 50 to 100 million and 50
to 100 million per year in terms of
so we're not we're not there yet yeah so
there i mean there are guys that are in
that 10 that 25 million they're using
offshore but it's for very specific
purposes what about like the 10 to 20
thousand
so bank of america is fine then okay
cool
as a financial person who does taxes and
again everybody is [ __ ] relating to
this kind of thing especially april
right what is like either the biggest
like
uh thing that a loophole in the system
or or just something that most normal
people would be able to like utilize you
know what i mean in order to either
reduce reliability or like just
something that would benefit them
financially especially for the people
that are subscribed at home to this
channel yeah yeah so i mean you gotta
click like and subscribe for the top
secret stuff
immediate twenty percent off
click on that button down there so like
the biggest thing that i find is is when
folks come to me and they ask me for so
we do a lot of tax strategy for clients
and they're like hey how do i reduce my
tax liability and they're just like a
w-2 employee there's not a lot of things
that we could do there if they're like a
nine-to-fiver because they take your tax
before you get your paycheck right they
take the taxpayer to take your paycheck
but on top of that they simplify the tax
code five years ago where you can't
deduct a whole lot of cool things so
usually my first question to ask folks
is number one do you operate a business
or have you been considering
starting a business whether you maybe
let's say for engineering architect
let's say instead you
still had that job but now you did some
consulting
now if you did some consulting and
brought some revenue or income in from
there there's a lot of expenses they
could operate against it that might not
be
traditionally tax deductible initially
but now are tax-deductible right so the
biggest thing really is like
if you're in a position where you're
like i'm paying way too much in tax what
can i do my first thing is hey do you
have a business or have you considered
starting a business step two let's say
we all have personal llc's right which
we all we all do we all do nice speak
for yourself
i'm a soul prop super exposed
i have a personal llc you have a
personal llc sex have her llc yep no
that one was taken
sexpert sex giver
i don't know if i have a personal llc
should i get one yeah you should bert
quan all right
quan
businesses as somebody so so let's say
uh you're like have you thought about
operating or do you own or operate your
own somebody's like yes then after that
what are like your main go-to things
that you're like boom boom boom you're
talking to the room right now
everyone here is a freelancer
or yeah so when it comes like tax
strategy right there's there's basically
three different things you can do you
have time shifting strategies time
shifting time shifting you have income
shifting strategies which mean you're
shifting income from one bracket to
another and then you have general
deductions so time shifting i've only
heard of general deductions my cpa must
suck
my cpa must suck what are the other two
what's time shifted so time shifting is
basically shifting the tax liability to
a point in the future so normal tools
that we would use are things like
setting up an ira or 401k okay okay
private pension plan even like very
specifically designed life insurance
policies can shift that tax liability to
a different point in the future
so it's time shifting today's video is
brought to you by audible now i've been
doing these long road trips as you know
yeah i do know vegas to la and sometimes
northern california if i feel like it
but one thing that i've been really
getting into is audiobooks and what i
realized too is i'm more of a audio
learner than a visual learner and so i'm
really into this whole like self-help
stuff right because every single time i
have free time
i feel like
aside from just being entertained i want
to like develop myself and be a bit of a
nerd so what i've been doing is going
through the list on audible and trying
to hack my brain right how do i deal
with my feelings how do i deal with this
and that and audible has a lot of dope
stuff in different categories from
podcasts to audiobooks there's just so
much content it's mind-blowing but
what's awesome if you're a new member
you get the first 30-day free a audio
entertainment all-in-one app it's like
joe's saying they got audio books
podcasts
comedy music performances they got all
kinds of stuff so it's a really cool app
it's all-encompassing and like what he
was saying is if you're new member you
get 30 days for free to try out so i
highly recommend it so if you want to
check it out go to audible.com
off the record or text off the record to
500 500 it's so easy go to audible.com
off the record or text off the record to
500 500. income shifting is shifting
your income bracket from where you are
in a high bracket to a lower bracket and
you can either do it by setting up
specially designed c corporations if you
have that type of revenue
um even paying kids what's that type of
revenue you need to have to squirm
again it's like it's kind of like real
that's a great question it's really
specific based on a person's situation
so a good example is i had a client he
had a business that was pushing about 15
million dollars a year in revenue his
net profit is a million
and he was trying to find ways to reduce
today his net was a million it was very
labor intensive what yeah after 15
that's crazy yeah there's a lot of labor
involved it's a very labor-intensive
business that he operated and so for him
he was like hey i have these expenses
that i can't deduct because it's in this
s corp structure
so it's like well if we created a c corp
that houses these things i'm getting
super in the weeds now but if we create
a specially designed c-corp that houses
these things you could legitimately
deduct it and you're pulling off of your
income and you're reducing your tax by
that so that's one another one that
might be more common is like for me i
have an 18 year old kid
i bought him a car paid for his car
insurance that's not normally not
deductible so instead what i did is i
hadn't worked for me he can make 12
grand a year from income from me on a
tax-free basis so i'm going from a high
tax bracket where i'm at to zero where
he's at and i'm basically deducting
things that are always going to buy for
them that's common a lot of people
employ their family members and make
them officers of companies and then when
you go on a trip or whatever it's a
business expense or whatever but i think
yeah the key though to not be illegal is
you have to bring some sort of income
you can't just have a business just to
write off [ __ ] cash only
so that that's a really good point right
i love this hobby
hobby how do we do this like a hobby to
the irs is like it's non-profit mode of
generating if it's a hobby the arsenal
doesn't allow you to deduct losses so
it's got to be for profit motives
right and then so the last thing the
third one is deducting shifting strategy
so just being really creative with wakey
deduct like so for example like i run a
lot of my business out of my home
and typically for a home office expense
you can only deduct that room or one
room
for that purpose but as an s-corporation
i could actually lease a portion of my
residence back to my company so it's
paying the lease for that portion
because i'm shooting content all around
i have clients come over i've got
employees come over because i knew that
strategy when you lease a home but i was
gonna ask like when you own a home how
would you do it and that makes sense you
lease a portion of your home to the
business yeah you become a landlord to
your business so good and then so you
pick up that income on your individual
side but then you offset it by the
expenses to operate the property there's
so many clever ways to do it you're
explaining so well yeah like a dummy
like i can understand you know you can't
understand i don't
what got you into like accounting and
and tax law and all this stuff like yeah
man that's a really good question so
like you went from owning a uh what like
a like a like a like a chop shop no i'm
just kidding like a
like a auto mechanic you know like
improving rice rockets and stuff and
whatever to accounting so i i went from
that and then i got into financial
planning the insurance and financial
planning industry and this is back in
2008. so 2008 the stock market was
booming this right before lehman
brothers crashed and i ironically needed
a tax deduction so my dad was like hey
why don't you
get into the tax business
and i ended up buying um four franchises
this company called liberty tax oh
that's how i got started in the tax
business so i got into the tax business
and then lehman brothers collapsed the
entire financial market collapsed my
entire financial planning business
got decimated and i was just in a tax
business
um as a person under did you cry oh dude
it was painful times like house got
foreclosed on oh my god the whole whole
it was a [ __ ] show but did you cry
though oh i definitely cried that's cry
tears
not tears of joy tears of sadness but
seriously though like when you hit rock
bottom like that
do you like what are your thoughts at
that point i mean it was tough like i
had a young kid and now still married at
the time it was like how was he when i
got into the tax business 13 years ago
so he was [ __ ] five wow wow
that's a scary [ __ ] time crazy i
still remember that packing up the house
because the house is being foreclosed on
and then moving out to worcester
massachusetts for the first part of the
year as we're building at this office
we're sleeping in the back of the office
to make it work yeah that's crazy that's
a really cool [ __ ] story though but
to know i know where you are at now and
it's like it's like that i mean that
entrepreneurial like ups and downs it's
the
you signed up for this kind of
work
you know it's like this is the life you
just
you have two businesses and it just
disappears and then now you got to do it
all over again the number of times i've
i've restarted and like like
entrepreneurship is interesting right
you gotta finish that sentence
how many times did you receive it yeah
yeah yeah i think a lot of people don't
hear that right now the number of times
i failed and restarted
so many times just number of times hit
rock bottom yeah so
the first one was my automotive business
this is 2001. my business partner and i
we end up having a falling out i ended
up walking away from a million dollar
business yeah because we had a lawsuit
all this stuff that was part number one
part number two is 2008 i had this great
financial planning business
got into a liberty tax that where my
main source of income collapsed house
got foreclosed on moved out to worcester
massachusetts to run this business
just a big struggle
and then like seven years ago same thing
i helped my ex-wife at the time with her
her youtube channel and we got this like
huge subscriber number stuff like that
ended up getting divorced again started
from scratch
right so like because that was the
channel was like the partnership and so
she left with that and then you had to
restart so i mean it's that life is just
like this beautiful journey and like
it's a duality in life you have these
ups and downs doesn't sound beautiful at
all
he makes it sound soft but it still
still sounds a little tough
but like those lows those low moments
help you really appreciate the high
moments and maybe i'm just just like
this is my like you're speaking from a
high moment
so when i look at your your board eight
be like
this is so high
it's one of
you
my
highest
love life
you bring up a really good point because
i think um i was like when i was hearing
your story i'm like man i'm so lucky i
don't have any lows
like
and then i'm like
wait a minute i do i just don't maybe
recognize it as a low because i can't
accept it
so i'll have to create some type of oh i
want this to happen i want to be in debt
for 200 grand with the government
because [ __ ] it i'm i'm a dj right so
i'll create these things in my head and
i'm like oh and then it gives me the
courage to just pay it off and i'm done
but then the effect that it had it's
almost like delusional right where like
it's like uh yeah i wasn't in a bad
place it's like the michael jordan's
thing right the last dance seems like i
took that person but i but i think i've
hit rock bottom a couple of times and
maybe emotionally felt it but my mind
didn't recognize it you're like there
right now aren't you well
i play it
all right i'm gonna turn it up a real
hot
you went through a divorce what was that
like
like what led to it
how was that why did it happen and then
no that's a that's a really good
question so like okay in like in
relationships by no means is it's just
one person right it's it's a it's a
two-way street
it's two people working together to make
things worse so it's her fault so yeah
mostly mostly 60 40.
but there's a combination of factors
that had happened so i was raised in a
cult i met my ex-wife in a cult so our
like our mental framework was kind of
like
wait i wonder if our cult's big crazier
than your fault let's see let's duel it
out right now battle of the cold there's
so many good you got to finish these
sentences hold on his eighth day
adventist eighth day god
he's even eighth day adventists
wait you're both
you're both from the same cult whoa okay
so let's let's backtrack a little bit
yes can you say it or not yeah i could
say it what is it so it's it's a long
name it's called the supreme master
ching hai international meditation
association it's still an active force
today i still have family members in it
supreme supreme master ching hai
international
ching
meditation international meditation is
that that buddhist group that
i think i've heard well there's another
name you've gone to like the loving hut
vegan restaurants they're part of the
group oh so they're always just saying
supreme master you know it's some
culture yes
you're not supreme master bart
does this call have a profit yes yeah so
there is a leader to the cult and it's
been around for quite a while it's based
out of taiwan for quite a while and it
you know at its peak i think it had over
100 000 members whoa so your parents and
her parents were in it yeah and then you
were raised in it so this was normal
life for you guys normal life yeah yeah
it's part of that so like internally
like the mental framework was very
different and then when you come back to
the outside world you're like oh [ __ ]
this is what life is supposed to be so
that's how we met and like kind of like
our relationship always had some
struggle because of that
um and then for what caused the struggle
if you guys like kind of had common
ground in that area i think the biggest
thing is just like you know
you know that's a that's a great
question um there's a combination of
things like colts are really unique and
there's this framework of what defines
to be a cult so one of the main
frameworks is does it does that cult or
that group influence who you're supposed
to hang out with and how you make
decisions and judgments in life yeah
yeah so in part of that group like if we
were to hang out with more people from
the outside or have our friends like we
would get karma and it would be harder
for us to become enlightened
so it would pull us away from the
outside so we didn't have a great friend
group and the challenge like
relationships and marriages and this is
this doesn't have to be an occult too is
sometimes we rely on our partners to be
our best friend our lover the mother of
a kid like all these things that's
that's a lot of pressure that we put on
that person
and so we rely on having great friends
that we could maybe shoot the [ __ ] with
maybe talk about things that maybe we we
want to have a sounding board before we
talk to our wife i didn't have that
yeah so a lot of cult and heavy
religious stuff it's like you can't even
say your real things because then
they'll judge you or like it's like it's
not real friends and stuff
at least that's how i felt like there's
like the subconscious and it's it's it's
not like the group said it but there's
always a subconscious internal judgment
of yourself and us as asian americans we
typically become like much more harsh in
our inner language than what we say to
other people yeah so like that was me
like i had a lot of inner judgment damn
because i was always concerned of like
[ __ ] if i do this i'm not going to get
enlightened if i do this i'm not going
to get liberty in this one lifetime
you know if in like part of it too like
if you had if you had sex or like you
made love to your your partner you would
actually lose the you you'd have to work
harder to become enlightened because now
you're more in the physical body as
opposed to focused on
your meditation and i'm working so hard
on you
that's great
yeah so there was there was a really a
lot there and then as we got out of the
cult the challenge i had is i always
lost myself at work my escapism was from
work
and so in a relationship i would be
physically present but not mentally
present because my mind would always be
in work and then you combine that to
youtube and social media world where
you're always being analyzed non-stop
all the time yeah like we're like
everything is about shooting content
like family vacations would be family
vacations you'd be shooting content
and so the challenge that i had is i was
not good at set creating boundaries yeah
that was my fault right and i wasn't
great at communicating and all these
different things right and you know
obviously she had her challenges we are
what was she good at yeah talk about
that enough about you man
i mean i you know i don't want to i'm
not the kind of person that that says
anything bad about anybody put her on
blast
that was definitely like for me a big
challenge do you for cold culture
do you acknowledge it's a cult
while you're in it or do you only
recognize the cult after out dude
so like when you're in a cult like
you've been indoctrinated and you have
this belief that you're doing everything
right like we believe we're saving the
world and everything but it's like an
abusive relationship yeah your homies on
the outside like yo that relationship's
talks like he's like oh man
i know i know i mean i got the black
eyes and [ __ ] like that but it's good
everything's good and it's it's even
worse because you were born into it i
think that man is hard fruits are
ingrained right
i was 12 when i got into the group but
that's still very much like but if it's
such a formidable time in your life
right yeah if it's reinforced by your
parents you have relatives your whole
community everyone you know your wife
like
there's a there's a terminology for it
where it's like a uh something bias
right where um
where
if your life depends on something
people don't want to leave it
so like so like pastors a lot of the
times you know they want to they won't
even consider that maybe christianity or
something might not be the thing to
believe you know and then because they
have a salary from the church they have
the whole community in the church so for
them they can't even question it exactly
so a lot of the times if you belong to
an institution that also is your
livelihood a lot of people make it's
extremely difficult because there's
nothing you can say to even bend that
reality and then you have this this
veiled threat and it's not a
communicated threat but a veiled thread
of like if you leave this group you lose
your entire friend group
right your entire community that's part
of it the
the unintent not unintentionally they
subconsciously isolate you from the
outside world and then they're like this
is where all your homies are at
so if you realize that it's no longer a
right thing to do and you leave you're
back in the world with nobody right so
like for me like my identity was
shattered like when i decided to leave
the group that's another freaking crazy
story how old were you when you decided
to leave the group it was pretty recent
it was um i think i was like 31. that's
pretty [ __ ] crazy yeah i've been
waiting to leave jk
it's only been like a year it's a free
mastermind friends in the car scene were
also in that cult no no so like the car
scene i was in the cult during the car
scene well i mean
i was i was in the car scene when i was
still in the cult um but you never mixed
them never mix them yeah never mix them
like that was for me like where i
actually was in touch with like real
people
the car scene like the car scene for me
is like it's like not like an escape but
not necessarily just an escape but that
was my community
i love the car race horse yeah
this 20 minutes is not enough man it's
not enough yeah we have seven minutes we
haven't even got to the divorce story
what he's learned he just got so stuck
with the cult [ __ ]
[Music]
you